[Music]
the road to alberta's busiest border
crossing remains open but the protesters
have not gone away
for several days rcmp have remained at
the site of two illegal protests traffic
is getting through but the crowd
continues to cause significant delays
protesters vowing to stay put until not
just the federal vaccine mandate for
cross supporter truckers is lifted but
until every last coven 19 restriction
goes away no responsible government
makes policy by negotiating with people
engaged in such unlawful conduct period
full stop
still the premiers of both alberta and
saskatchewan have promised that
provincial restrictions including proof
of vaccine programs will not be in place
much longer covett is not ending but
government restrictions on your rights
and freedoms those will be ending and
ending very soon both provinces plan to
roll out details early this week but
with health care systems still under
pressure medical experts have concerns
from a medical and from a public health
perspective this is not optimal by any
means alberta and saskatchewan have been
down this road before
after lifting all restrictions last
summer both provinces experienced a
delta-fueled fourth wave that
overwhelmed hospital icus many people
lost their lives irretrievably i mean a
lot you know people families you know
lost their
their loved ones and hospitalization
numbers are even higher now doctors
aren't alone in these fears the way
the government opened it up for stampede
last year really actually kind of pissed
me off because it was like hey there's
no kovid we're fine hey party do
whatever you want so let's open up
responsibly
and because i don't want to be shut down
again there may be a divide on how to
proceed but after two long years
everyone is so tired of covered 19.
heather eurex west global news calgary